[Music]
what I'm dead ring a ding ding you got
it buo St Peter it's my name and a title
don't wear either out oh wow I can't
believe I I'm in heaven I'm going to see
Nana again and Drew and baile take it
easy guy with a surprising amount of
dead friends you're not in yet these are
the outskirts of Heaven you still have
to be let in the gates so
what are you doing you never been to
like a fancy restaurant where the Mater
D is like we are all booked and then
he's like
unless you want to bribe I did not say
that I did not say that for all intents
and purposes I just have a cough you can
get sick in heaven
nope no you
can't
uh I died in my sleep so I don't really
have any
money
okay well let's let's figure this out
let's talk it out uh what what uh what
uh what else could you
do something you could do even if you
don't have anything on you maybe to
something I have on
me talking about a robe
boner I'm not gay oh don't worry that's
an earth thing up here there's no such
thing as gay or straight or
bribes I I don't really know what to say
you don't really have to say anything
this is more of a do
situation but I don't think God would
want me to it's not about what you
should or shouldn't do up here that's
Earth thinking this is an eternal
landscape where all Consciousness has
come to merge into one Eternal conscious
so there's no right or wrong or light or
dark it's all happening Everything is
Everything and it's occurring at the
same
time so lose the
shirt you want to meet John Lennon right
he plays a concert every night mostly
new stuff then he plays imagine gets
real awkward when he gets to the imagine
there's no Heaven part it's a big
laugh all right
now let's get this St Peter past your
ply
Gates no God no it was it was a test it
it was a test no it was a it was to see
if you get in and you do you get in you
passed so the test to get into heaven is
to see if I'll blow you it's uh it's a
parable yeah you have to look past the
story to see the the true meaning of
Christmas kidding I was fuing with you
this whole time don't look so mad
normally I let the guy blow me
first keep that shirt off beautiful let
God enjoy what he
made